bien mesdames messieurs bonjour à toutes
et à tous cette semaine a permis un
certain nombre de constats d'annonce et
de nouvelles qui en disent long sur les
avancées réalisées en france depuis cinq
ans en cinq ans nous avons connu des
crises et notamment la crise sanitaire
que nous affrontons encore mais en cinq
ans sur tout et malgré ces crises notre
pays a aussi changé sa vie économique
s'est aussi amélioré notre économie
s'est redressée le travail paye enfin
davantage et nous avons montré que le
chômage de masse n'était pas une
fatalité dans notre pays bien sûr tout
n'a pas été parfait bien sûr certains de
nos compatriotes connaissent encore de
profondes difficultés bien sûr la france
a encore de grands défis devant elle et
certaines réformes importantes nous
attendent encore mais aujourd'hui bien
plus qu il y a cinq ans ou dix ans les
français peuvent regarder l'avenir avec
confiance c'est sans doute ce constat
qui fait enrager les professionnels du
pessimisme les amateurs du déclin et
tous ceux qui font commerce d'un
prétendu déclin inexorable de notre pays
pour nous la conquête ce n'est pas qu'un
état d'esprit ce sont des actes c'est un
bilan et ce sont des faits car oui en
deux mots depuis cinq ans et encore
aujourd'hui nous avançons et cette
semaine nous l'a rappelé nous avançons
dans le redressement économique en ce
début de semaine un nouveau sommet tous
france a mis en lumière à nouveau qu'en
matière d'attractivité économique la
france a retrouvé la première division
mondiale 4 milliards d'euros
d'investissements ont été annoncés lundi
ses dix mille emplois qui seront créés
lien entre 2017 et 2020 5300 projets
d'investissement étrangers ont été
recensés avec à la clé cent quarante
mille emplois la france a été classé à
deux reprises comme le pays le plus
attractif d'europe pour les
investissements étrangers dans les
classements indépendant le regard des
investisseurs a changé sur notre pays et
c'est une excellente nouvelle
dans le même temps le secteur numérique
a connu un essor sans précédent qui
illustre la d'une 25e licorne qui a été
faite cette semaine ce changement c'est
les résultats de cinq ans de politique
ambitieuse de baisses d'impôts de
réformes courageuses de notre marché du
travail aidé action résolue de soutien
aux entreprises ordonnance travail
réforme de l'assurance chômage baisse
des impôts de production baisse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés baisse des
cotisations pour augmenter les salaires
relocalisation et réindustrialisation
déploiement dès la première seconde du
quoi qu'il en coûte face à la crise nous
avons asie un million de nouveaux
emplois ont été créés depuis 2017 nous
avons enfin recommencer à créer des
emplois industriels est désormais la
france est un pays où l'on relocalise
nous avons fait des jeunes aussi notre
priorité et 700 mille contrats
d'apprentissage ont été signés rien
qu'en 2021 ce sont les réformes du début
du mandat qui ont permis le soutien aux
entreprises et notre rebond exceptionnel
face à la crise qui a été saluée je veux
le souligner encore récemment par le
prix nobel d'économie paul krugman qui a
jugé que la réponse française à la crise
économique liée au qu'ovide était la
plus efficace sur la planète les faits
sont là ils sont à têtu notre croissance
s'élève à près de 7% en 2021 et nous
allons connaître le taux de chômage le
plus bas depuis 15 ans malgré la crise
nous avons rompu avec des années
d'économies atone de chômage de masse
cette reprise bénéficie à tout le monde
car oui nous avançons pour le pouvoir
d'achat et la réduction de la pauvreté
dans notre pays grâce aux mesures qui
ont été mises en place pendant la crise
l'insee estime que ce sont 400 mille
personnes qui ont été protégés de tomber
dans la pauvreté nous avons fait en
sorte que les salaires augmentent sans
pénaliser la compétitivité de nos
entreprises je veux rappeler les
engagements qui avaient été pris et qui
ont été tenues notamment sur la prime
d'activité sur les baisses de coach de
cotisations sur la baisse massive de
l'impôt sur le revenu tout cela c'est un
13e et un quasi 14e mois pour un salarié
qui travaille au smic c'est aussi le cas
avec la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation nous avons limité l'impact
des menaces sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français avec l'indemnité inflation et
le bouclier tarifaire qui bloque
l'augmentation exponentielle du prix du
gaz et de l'est récitez grâce aux
mesures prises par le gouvernement la
hausse des prix de l'électricité restera
limitée à 4% au 1er février si nous
avions si nous n'avions pas pris ces
mesures comme nous y invite aujourd'hui
étrangement certains les prix de
l'électricité aurait augmenté de 30 à 45
% sur la facture des français et des
entreprises nous avons donc fait
économiser en moyenne 300 euros sur
l'année à chaque foyer 300 euros de
dépenses d'électricité qui ont été
évités grâce aux mesures prises par le
gouvernement nous avons augmenté aussi
les salaires des soignants des
professeurs et des gardiens de la paix
nous avons enfin fait confiance à la
concertation et nous l'avons vu mardi
encore avec la signature d'un accord
salarial historique dans la branche
hôtellerie cafés restauration un accord
qui a acté des revalorisations de plus
de 15% sur les plus bas salaires du
secteur nous avançons au sida le
rétablissement de nos comptes publics
durant ce quinquennat a malgré les
épreuves nous avons gardé le cap de la
responsabilité et contrairement à la
gestion budgétaire de la crise de 2008
nous avons fait du sérieux budgétaire
une préoccupation constante lors d'une
communication effectuée ce matin en
conseil des ministres le ministre chargé
des comptes publics a annoncé que nos
comptes se redressait plus vite que
prévu après la crise avec un déficit
réduit à 7 % pour 2021 par rapport aux
prévisions cela représente une
amélioration de 30 4 milliards d'euros
ces résultats nous les devons à notre
croissance et à notre politique de
restrictions sanitaires proportionnée
minimal une étude du conseil d'analysé
économique a ainsi établi que sans le
pass sanitaire l'économie française
aurait perdu six milliards d'euros en
2021 nous avons aujourd'hui 20 milliards
de recettes supplémentaires et comme
promis comme prévu comme annoncé nous
les mettrons à profit pour accélérer la
réduction de notre déficit nous avançons
aussi vers une europe plus fortes
ambitieuses et protectrice sous ce
quinquennat la france a renoué avec son
ambition européenne grâce à la vision
profondément européenne ambitieux du
président de la république la france a
porté avec l'allemagne un plan de
relance européen qui a évité une crise
économique d'ampleur inédite tout en
accélérant les transitions verte et
numérique de notre économie l'europe
nous a permis grâce à son action résolue
disposer de stocks conséquents suffisant
régulier de vaccins y compris pour
effectuer la campagne de rappel l'europe
celle que nous construisons fait preuve
d'unité face aux provocations de nos
voisins et pour la défense de l'état de
droit d'ambition en matière
environnementale en matière numérique et
en matière sociale et de fermeté sur les
questions sécuritaires et migratoire la
présidence française du conseil européen
sera à n'en pas douter l'occasion de
nouvelles grandes avancées dans ce grand
projet démocratique progressiste et
pacifiste que nous portons nous avançons
enfin pas à pas vers ce qui nous
espérons pourrait être une vie plus
facile encore avec le virus ne nous y
trompons pas la situation sanitaire est
encore tendue le nombre
d'hospitalisations reste très élevé et
le nombre de cas détectés est encore en
sensible augmentation hier ce sont plus
de 400 mille personnes qui ont été
testées positives et nous comptons
désormais en moyenne plus de 320 milles
contaminations chaque jour pour vous
donner une idée la probabilité qu'une
personne au moins soit positive dans un
événement qui rassemble 50 personnes est
de l'ordre de 96 % l'épidémie est encore
en expansion mais si nous espérons comme
l'indiquent certains scientifiques que
le pic omicron approche nous constatons
en réanimation une diminution une baisse
de 15% d admission en soins critiques et
donc le nombre total de patients qui
diminuent également
si nous tenons si nous avons réussi à
éviter le scénario catastrophe c'est
bien parce que le plein le vaccin a
pleinement joué son rôle de bouclier
selon les données de santé publique
france il ya aujourd'hui 15 fois moins
d'admission en soins critiques parmi les
personnes contaminées qu'en mars 2021
c'est grâce à la vaccination si nous
tenons c'est grâce au pass sanitaire qui
selon une étude indépendante à nouveau
paru cette semaine du conseil d analyse
économique a permis d'accroître de 13
points notre couverture vaccinale
d'éviter des milliers d'hospitalisations
et 4000 décès le pass vaccinale adopté
ce week-end constitue une nouvelle étape
de notre stratégie d'incitation et de
protection maximale il montre déjà ses
effets puisque depuis son annonce il y à
un mois plus d'un million de français
ont choisi d'aller réaliser la première
injection de vaccin si nous tenons c'est
aussi bien sûr parce que les français
ont été d'une remarquable responsabilité
vaccin parce responsabilités voilà ce
qui nous permet il nous a permis et nous
permettra de tenir durant ces prochaines
semaines alors que beaucoup nous
invitait à refermer le pays à la proche
des fêtes nous avons tenu bon et nous
avons eu raison à ceux qui aujourd'hui
veulent faire croire aux français que
les mesures en vigueur seraient
disproportionnées je le redis regarder
autour de nous et rappelez-vous les
néerlandais ont passé noël sous
confinement et le sont encore les
allemands ont dû limiter les fêtes en se
restreignant avec un nombre de convives
maximale cet hiver les irlandais ne
pouvais plus aller au restaurant après
20 heures et les belges les autrichiens
les danois ont aussi dû s'astreindre à
ne plus aller au restaurant à 1h
anticipée de la soirée les danois n'ont
pas pu aller au spectacle tout comme les
italiens d'ailleurs quant aux habitants
de catalogne le couvre-feu qui leur
était imposé depuis la veille de noël ne
sera levée que vendredi à côté de tout
cela les français eux ont pu passer noël
et le nouvel an et le nouvel an
quasiment sans contrainte les fêtes ont
été quasi normal en france les
restaurants sont restés ouverts sans
restriction d'horaire en france les
salles de spectacle et les cinémas
continue à accueillir du public en
france chacun a pu retrouver les siens
et passer les fêtes en famille ou avec
ses proches ça n'était pas le cas chez
beaucoup de nos voisins c'est grâce au
vaccin c'est grâce au pass c'est grâce à
notre responsabilité en france nous
avons fait le choix courageux d'un pays
ouvert nous sommes restés fidèles à
notre priorité le maintien de l'école
ouverte comme depuis le premier jour de
cette crise nous avons maintenu notre
vie sociale notre vie culturelle notre
vie économique sans jamais céder à la
panique et au défaitisme malgré les
appels incessants de leurs partisans
nous faisons aussi le choix avec les
tests pris en charge par la sécurité
sociale pour la grande majorité des
français avec les vaccins gratuit et
bien sûr les soins pris en charge d'une
protection maximale des français par
notre modèle collectif notre modèle
social est aussi notre meilleur bouclier
et nous pouvons en être fiers
compte tenu de la situation sanitaire du
besoin exprimé évidemment de clarté des
français sur le calendrier des quelques
contraintes restantes dans notre pays
nous avons pris ce matin un certain
nombre de décisions en conseil de
défense et de sécurité nationale le
premier ministre avec le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé tiendra une
conférence de presse ce soir à 19 heures
ils présenteront ainsi un calendrier
précis un calendrier détaillé de levée
progressive des dernières mesures dans
notre pays mesdames et messieurs ce
conseil des ministres a également été
l'occasion d'adopter deux textes le
premier tech c'est un projet de loi
ratifiant une ordonnance sur
l'utilisation et l'évaluation des
biotechnologies le but de ce texte est
de mieux évaluer les caractéristiques et
les éventuels risques des ogm notamment
en confiant ses missions à l' agence
nationale de sécurité sanitaire de
l'alimentation de l'environnement et du
travail et un comité dédié auprès du
ministère chargé de la recherche par
ailleurs ce texte simplifie la vie de
nos agriculteurs en permettant
l'utilisation sans déclaration de gm
avec un risque nul pour l'environnement
dans des espaces confinés le second
texte était également agricole puisqu'il
s'agissait d'une ordonnance portant sur
l'organisation du réseau des chambres
d'agriculture
l'objectif de ce texte est de faciliter
la création des chambres régionales
d'agriculture tout en maintenant un
réseau dense d'élus au plus près des
territoires enfin la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation a présenté un bilan
de la première année de la stratégie
nationale quantique annoncé par le
président de la république le 21 janvier
dernier cette stratégie vise à créer 16
mille emplois et à former 5000 nouveaux
chercheurs ingénieurs et techniciens
grâce à l'investissement des 8 milliards
d'euros dont un milliard d'euros de
l'état sur cinq ans notre objectif est
clair placer la france à la plainte du
cantique et bâtir une filière
industrielle compétitive en un an de
nombreuses actions ont été engagées 150
millions d'euros ont été investis dans
un programme d'équipement prioritaires
et 60 millions d'euros ont d'ores et
déjà été consacrés à la formation un
certain nombre de projets ambitieux ont
également été lents c'est je pense en
particulier au lancement des travaux
pour la création du premier super
calculateur hybride au monde
voilà mesdames et messieurs ce que je
pouvais vous dire du conseil des
ministres de ce matin et je me tiens à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions et nous commençons avec sami
saxy
bonjour monsieur le ministre ça me fera
que si on avait de kannad plus sérieuse
je reçois ma question alors vous l'avez
dit du coup jean castex va annoncer ce
soir à 19h les mesures est ce qu'on va
vers un allègement des restrictions et
sur quel type justement d'allègement
on peut avoir le calendrier un peu en
avance et j'imagine que ça va être
compliqué mais bon je vous pose la
question quand même et puis une autre
question c'est je pense plus important
hier boris johnson lui a annoncé la fin
de toutes les restrictions à partir du
27 janvier dont plus de matches nuls par
plus de passes sanitaires plus aucune
restriction or nous en france on va dans
quelques jours promulgué le pass
vaccinale sans doute si le conseil
constitutionnel valide le texte alors on
se compare toujours avec les
britanniques est ce que nous en france
ce principe de précaution a été poussée
à l'extrême est ce qu'on n'est pas à
contre-courant finalement de de cette
épidémie merci vous bon alors je vois
bien à l'exercice auquel on va se livrer
là dans les prochaines minutes c'est que
vous allez essayer d'obtenir de moi que
je vous donne en avance les annonces qui
seront faites par le premier ministre et
le ministre de la santé vous le fait
d'ailleurs très bien et très subtilement
j'ai pu constater à plusieurs reprises
mais moi même aussi je me suis je crois
améliorée dans ma manière de ne pas trop
lâches et les informations évidemment
qui doivent être annoncées par le
premier ministre mais je vais quand même
essayer de répondre à vos questions en
tout cas pour vous donner la philosophie
et peut-être d'ailleurs en commençant
pas répondre à votre deuxième question
avant la première on a aujourd'hui une
situation sanitaire qui est assez
disparate en europe ce qu'on constate
c'est que la vague omicron a été très
forte dans beaucoup d'endroits qu'elle
diminue que le pic est passé et qu'elles
diminuent rapidement au royaume-uni
qu'elle démarre et qu'elle augmente très
fort dans d'autres pays je pense
notamment à l'allemagne et donc vous
avez certains pays le royaume uni en
particulier où le pic est passé où la
vague diminue fortement qui
effectivement allège un certain monde 30
et vous avez d'autres pays où la vague
omicron démarre aujourd'hui progresse de
fassions de façon très forte qui eux
mêmes se pose la question d'accroître
encore les mesures et de renforcer les
mesures on en est nous en france on a
connu deux vagues en même temps la vague
delta qui a commencé plus tard chez nous
qu'ailleurs si pour le coup elle a
entamé une sérieuse des crues ont
indiqué les scientifiques ce qui
explique que la situation en réanimation
s'améliore et que le nombre de personnes
hospitalisées en réanimation diminue et
nous avons connu la vague omicron où
pour le coup il ya toujours une
augmentation forte du taux d'incidence
je veux insister sur ce point il ya des
espoirs d'un pic qui pourrait arriver
prochainement je relaie les propos ici
qui ont été exprimées en début de
semaine par le professeur fontanet qu
autorité en la matière il ya cet espoir
mais nous constatons qu'il ya encore une
augmentation du taux d'incidence mais
nous savons dans le même temps que le
variant omicron entraîne moins de cas
sévères que le variant delta ce qui
explique que la situation s'améliore en
réanimation est par ailleurs nous avons
un couverture vaccinale qui est qui très
large l'arrivée du pass vaccinale
permettra aussi probablement d'assouplir
un certain nombre de mesures parce que
c'est un outil nouveau dont nous
disposons qui permet de renforcer la
sécurité dans un certain nombre de lieux
et donc c'est dans ce contexte là que le
premier ministre avec olivier ferrand
vont annoncer ce soir un calendrier
précis détaillé d'allègement des mesures
qui restent aujourd'hui en vigueur dans
notre pays pour donner des perspectives
aux français qui les attendent
évidemment je veux quand même insisté
sur le fait qu on part d'un niveau de
restriction et de mesures qui est
inférieur à ce que nous constatons chez
la plupart de nos voisins on ne parle
pas en france contrairement à ce qu'on
constate chez nos voisins que j'évoquais
dans mon intervention liminaire de se
poser la question de la fin d'un
couvre-feu de la fin d'un confinement de
la réouverture de restaurants de bars de
théâtre ou de cinéma mais il reste des
mesures je pense notamment aux
discothèques qui sont toujours fermés je
veux vraiment avoir un mot pour elle
parce que c'est très dur c'est
probablement l'établissement qui a été
le type d'établissement qui a été le
plus fermé depuis le début de la crise
on sait que c'est un lieu où il peut y
avoir plus de contaminations qu'ailleurs
pour des raisons évident qu'ils
attendent des perspectives claires
précises pour la réouverture évidemment
elles seront données il y à des jauges
qui s'applique encore dans notre pays
pour les grands événements de mille
personnes en intérieur 5000 personnes en
extérieur là aussi les acteurs concernés
notamment dans la vie culturelle ou
sportive attentes des perspectives sur
le calendrier d'allègement de ces
mesures il ya aujourd'hui un télétravail
qui est obligatoire de manière
importante là aussi les acteurs
économiques les salariés attendent des
perspectives d'allègement et un
calendrier communiqué par le
gouvernement il ya impasse vaccinale qui
va entrer en vigueur là aussi je pense
que les français attendent une
clarification sur le calendrier de son
entrée en vigueur et sur les conditions
dans lesquelles il pourrait être retiré
dès lors que la situation sanitaire le
permettra sur tous ces sujets le premier
ministre et olivier ferrand s'exprimant
cet après midi mais évidemment ce sont
eux qui feront les annonces
france info il ya aujourd'hui une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation des
enseignants parmi les questions qu'ils
se posent aujourd'hui ou en tout cas
s'ils me demandent au gouvernement c'est
notamment le report des épreuves
anticipées du baccalauréat est ce que
cette question a été abordée ce matin en
conseil de défense et littéraire et es
ce que vous avez pris une décision
alors on va d'abord je veux rendre
hommage au travail des enseignants de
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
qui depuis début de cette crise sont
extrêmement mobilisés je le disais je le
rappelais la fait le choix de maintenir
l'école ouverte on a maintenu notre
école ouverte deux fois plus qu'en
allemagne trois fois plus qu'en italie
quatre fois plus qu'aux états unis on
n'a pas à le regretter je crois quand on
regarde la situation sanitaire dans ces
pays qui n'est pas particulièrement n'a
pas été particulièrement meilleure que
chez nous et quand on regarde surtout
les retards accumulés par beaucoup
d'élèves dans un certain nombre de pays
qui ont fermé beaucoup leur école nous
n'avons pas à regretter ce choix d'avoir
maintenu les écoles ouvertes évidemment
maintenir les écoles ouvertes dans un
contexte de circulation du virus cela
impose de prendre des mesures qui sont
des mesures contraignantes qui sont des
mesures difficiles pour les enseignants
pour les parents pour les enfants aussi
c'est pas anodin on le sait pour les
enfants de porter un masque c'est pas
anodin pour enfant de devoir faire
régulièrement des tests je pense qu'on a
tous dans notre famille dans notre
entourage et qu'on sait à quel point
c'est aussi difficile pour dans ce
contexte là il ya eu une mobilisation
jeudi dernier des enseignants qui a été
très suivi il ya eu je crois un dialogue
important qui a eu lieu le soir même
avec le premier ministre avec jean
michel blanquer avec olivier ferrand et
des mesures fortes qui ont été annoncées
qui répondait aux attentes
exprimées par les enseignants je pense à
l'arrivée des masques ffp2 je pense à la
question des capteurs de co2 je pense
aux 8000 recrutement à la fois pour
garantir les remplacements pour soulager
aussi le travail administratif des
directeurs d'école il ya notamment cette
question du calendrier des épreuves qui
a été abordé à ce moment-là ce qu'a
indiqué jean michel blanquer la semaine
dernière c'est que un travail de
concertation de dialogue avec les
représentants des enseignants avec les
lycéens allaient être conduits pour
prendre une décision c'est ce qui l'a
rappelé ce matin en conseil de défense
en indiquant que ce dialogue et que les
échanges avaient lieu ces derniers jours
qu'ils allaient se poursuivre pour
certains d'entre eux que dans les
prochains jours une décision sera prise
et communiqués par le ministre
oui ou non
dans les prochains jours je peux pas
vous donner de calendrier exact mais
évidemment moi je sais que ce soient les
lycéens ou les enseignants les familles
évidemment attendre de savoir assez
rapidement ce qu'il en sera on a entendu
les revendications qui est exprimé par
ces syndicats d enseignants et les
annonces seront faites dans les
prochains jours par jean-michel par jean
castex vous avez évoqué la question des
tests à l'école certains de nos voisins
pratique
des textes des
tests préventifs plutôt que réactifs est
ce que cette question n'a a également
été abordée est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait qui pourrait évoluer
je pense aux enfants allemands qui ce
test systématiquement en arrivant à
l'école le matin sur ce point je
laisserai le premier ministre olivier
ferrand s'exprimer on a aussi une
politique de tests préventifs en france
avec des tests itératif entre guillemets
où vous avez des équipes qui se
déplacent dans les établissements
scolaires et qui depuis le début de
cette épidémie procède régulièrement à
des tests des mêmes des tests salivaires
qui avait été mis en place pour pour
cela donc il ya aujourd'hui évidemment
cette dimension qui existe il ya aussi
une dimension de test lorsque des
enfants sont qu'à contacter mais je
laisserai mes collègues du gouvernement
s'exprimer plus en détail sur ce sujet
sylvie corps des sociétés de presse j'ai
deux questions très différentes la
première une précision sur ce que vous
avez dit concernant le battre en finale
vous avez dit mentionné que depuis son
annonce un million de personnes
ont fait la primo enfin la première
injection est ce que c'est le chiffre
total qui inclut les adultes et les
enfants puisque beaucoup pour les
enfants ça s'est ouvert récemment donc
c'est logique
qu'il le fasse bien sûr alors je me
crois que c'est un million c'est
uniquement les adultes mais je me tourne
vers mon équipe qui touche la tête dans
le bon sens et donc ça veut dire que
c'est la réponse correcte les enfants
c'est en plus évidemment mais de même
qu'on avait constaté au moment où le
pass sanitaire avait été annoncée le 12
juillet dernier par le président de la
république une augmentation très forte
des primo injection qui avait suivi
avant même que le pass sanitaire n'entre
en vigueur c'est la même chose qu'on a
constaté pour le pass vaccinale de même
que je pense que cela a aussi permis le
développement très rapide de la campagne
de rappel aujourd'hui que ce soit en
couverture vaccinale primo injection ou
en campagne de rappel la france est dans
le peloton de tête européen sur sa
campagne de vaccination ils ont le doit
notamment à ses outils du pass
sanitaires et bientôt du pass vaccinal à
une autre question suite à l'accident
qui a coûté la vie à gaspard ulliel on a
entendu des voix
c'est exprès suggéré que le port du
masque du casque pardon pourrait être
rendu obligatoire sur les pistes de ski
c'est le cas dans beaucoup de pays
européens notamment pour les enfants est
ce qu'il ya une réflexion du
gouvernement sur ce sujet de cette
mesure de précaution et à l'heure où la
france
pleure un acteur prodige
le cinéma perd un de ses fils les plus
prometteurs je trouve que ça n'est pas
tout à fait le moment de se lancer dans
ce genre
de débat de polémique je veux rendre
hommage à gaspard ulliel qui a été le
visage d'une nouvelle génération
d'acteurs qui a été un souffle de
création qui a été et sera toujours je
crois une source d'inspiration
je veux dire que je penserai à son fils
à sa compagne à sa famille à ses amis et
à tous les amoureux du cinéma
bonjour bastien g pour tf1 lci
j'aimerais revenir de seconde sur la
grève des enseignants est ce que le
président de la république a le mot elle
ce matin en conseil des ministres
concernant la colère de la colère de ses
enseignants est ce qu il a eu un mot
également au sujet des polémiques autour
de jean michel blanquer rs qui lui a
renouvelé sa
confiance et enfin sans détailler
évidemment le calendrier qui sera donné
ce soir est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
si la question du protocole dans les
écoles pourraient faire partie de ce
soir
nous avons eu la semaine dernière vous
vous en souvenez on en avait parlé au
moment du compte rendu du conseil des
ministres des discussions sur la
question de l'école sur l'application du
protocole sanitaire et sur la
mobilisation à venir à l'époque jeudi
dernier donc des enseignants le savent
été discuté à ce moment là le président
de la république a rappelé ce matin en
conseil des ministres qu'il y avait
évidemment un travail du gouvernement
pour faire en sorte que
les mesures qui sont mises en place à
l'école s'applique
j'allais dire en étant le moins
contraignant possible c'est des
contraintes donc voila mais s'applique
et soit adapté en permanence évidemment
aux conditions sanitaires et avec bon
sens c'est ce que nous constatons sur le
terrain il a rappelé que ce travail
avait été menée par le premier ministre
et par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale
bonjour mathieu collège bfm tv les des
navires russes sont en transit dans
plusieurs maires en ce moment le ton
monte entre les états unis et la russie
est ce qu'il a été question de la
situation en ukraine pendant ce conseil
débiner si oui est-ce que le qu'est ce
que le président a dit et puis peut-être
quelle est la position aujourd'hui de la
france face à ces menaces alors que on
entend assez peu finalement le
gouvernement sur sur cette question
d'abord il est toujours question de la
situation à l'international en conseil
des ministres puisque vous le savez dans
chaque conseil des ministres il y à une
communication du ministère des affaires
étrangères sur la situation
internationale sur ce sujet le président
de la république s'est exprimé hier
devant le parlement européen il était
interrogé et donc je n'ai pas de
déclaration supplémentaire à faire que
celles qui ont été faites par le
président de la république et que celles
qui seront probablement faites par le
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian puisque vous savez qu'une
réunion importante se tient aujourd'hui
même à bruxelles sur ce sujet
à nouveau bastia angers pour tf1 lci
quel est votre regard sur les échanges
qu'il ya eu hier entre le président de
la république et les eurodéputés
notamment français au parlement européen
yannick jadot manon aubry et jordan
bardet notamment beaucoup été critiqué
parce qu'on les a accusés de transformer
cet hémicycle européens ont finalement
en meeting de campagne français est ce
que le président de la république ne se
dit pas avec du recul aussi qu'il a une
part de responsabilité dans le fait
finalement d'avoir choisi d'assurer
cette présidence française de l'union
européenne en période de campagne
électorale parce que c'est pas une
responsabilité collective
je me souviens qu'on avait eu ce débat
sur le calendrier la présidence
française de l'union européenne et le
report
non donc peut-être pas revenir là dessus
moi ce que je vous dis avec certitude
c'est que les mêmes qui aujourd'hui font
mine de regretter que la présidence
française de l'union européenne
intervienne au moment où se tient une
élection présidentielle aurait été les
premiers si la france avait demandé à
renoncer pour un temps à sa présidence
française de l'union européenne à le
dénoncer en expliquant que la france
n'était pas au rendez vous de ses
responsabilités on aurait entendu les
mêmes critiques et voilà nous assumons
nos responsabilités dans un contexte
historique pour l'europe dans une crise
historique dans une relance historique
dans des défis historiques avec les
grandes plateformes avec le défi
migratoire avec la question
environnementale nous assumons nos
responsabilités et je pense que le
président de la république a montré hier
que c'est face à ces défis et à ses
responsabilités que nous allions agir
dans la présidence française de l'union
européenne après pour le reste écoutez
moi je vais pas faire du commentaire du
commentaire surtout que je pense que en
tout cas pour certains d'entre eux qui
se sont exprimés ce sont leurs amis
politiques qui en parlent le mieux j'ai
vu notamment le président je crois des
verts allemands regretté la teneur de la
déclaration et de la prise de parole de
celui qui représentait le groupe des
verts à ce moment là yannick jadot dans
l'hémicycle en indiquant que ça n'était
pas le lieu ni le moment d'importer un
débat de campagne présidentielle dans
dans ce moment donc voila moi je il ya
d'une certaine manière l'image assez
désolante qui a été montré par des
responsables de l'opposition qui ont
voulu faire de ce moment qui est un
moment profondément européen un moment
de campagne nationale et je crois que le
président de la république que ce soit
dans son intervention liminaire que ce
soit dans sa réponse aux interventions
des eurodéputés a montré que lui se
plaçait à la hauteur des enjeux c'est à
dire les enjeux européens qui sont
évidemment ceux qui nous mobilise
aujourd'hui
juste pour rebondir sur la question de
mon confrère est ce que vous observez
justement ça une violence dans
l'invectivé entre les politiques ont
voix il ya un président de la république
a aussi été hué quand il est arrivé au
parlement européen on constate quand
même qu'entre politique c'est très
compliqué de se parler est ce que vous
vous le constatez et quel est votre
regard il faut réécouter qui est qui et
quatre ou cinq militants à politiques
qu'ils soient mobilisés par une
formation politique pour un accueil
c'est pas très nouveau ça s'est toujours
fait c'est toujours organisé il ya des
partis qui sont très professionnels pour
organiser cela
moi ce que je veux dire c'est que
évidemment que nous avons besoin d'un
débat politique sur tous les sujets pas
uniquement sur la question de la
campagne sur les échéances électorales
qui soient respectueux et qui surtout à
mon sens soit tourné vers les
préoccupations et les attentes de nos
concitoyens et je crois que c'est ce
qu'on cherche à faire on cherche à
montrer et c'est ce qu'on va continuer à
faire même si nous constatons que dans
les oppositions certains ne sont pas sur
cette ligne là
aucun calendrier dévoilé ce soir pour
les français donc l'horizon d'égal pour
les français ce que l'horizon se dégage
également pour emmanuel maintenant pour
se lancer enfin officiellement dans la
campagne et l'ex là dessus j'ai pas la
fraude annonce ni de
d'éléments à vous donner supplémentaire
en plus présent la république a eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer sur ce sujet en
date c'était dans une interview dans un
face aux lecteurs parisiens dont vous
souvenez peut-être et donc j'ai pas
d'annoncés supplémentaires ou d'éléments
supplémentaires à vous donner sur ce
sujet là ce qui nous préoccupe vous le
voyez c'est de continuer à gérer cette
crise sanitaire en gardant une
proportion dans les mesures que nous
sommes amenés à prendre et je rappelle
encore une fois que nous avons tenu en
france cet hiver et notamment autour des
fêtes face à certains qui nous
appelaient nous pousser à prendre des
mesures de fermeture des écoles de
confinement de couvre-feu soit pour 31
décembre soit pour toutes les vacances
de fermeture des restaurants ou des bars
etc et nous avons obtenu avec des
mesures qui ont été prises qui ont un
impact que je ne nie pas encore une fois
sur le monde de la culture ou du sport
pour les grands événements sur les
discothèques évidemment mais nous avons
tenu avec ce choix d'avoir des mesures
proportionnées pour permettre à notre
pays de rester ouvert pour permettre aux
français de vivre le plus normalement
possible pendant ces fêtes et c'est la
même boussole d'avoir des mesures
proportionnées qui nous guide dans les
décisions que nous avons prises ce matin
qui seront annoncées par le premier
ministre ce soir
merci beaucoup et à la semaine prochaine